the only thing we can be sure of about
the future is that it will be absolutely
fantastic
[Music]
uh welcome everybody to the into the
impossible podcast production of the
Arthur C Clarke Center for human
imagination and the division of physical
sciences at UC San Diego and it's a
treat to welcome sir Roger Penrose back
to UC San Diego pleasure certainly yes
yeah we're uh certainly need to be back
thank you we're extracting a lot out of
you in this visit we are
grateful to you for hosting uh to be
hosting these many talks that you're
giving you gave one talk that was uh
more than standing room only earlier
today uh you're doing this interview now
and tomorrow you're giving another talk
uh it's really quite generous of you
thank you so much and I've come to
expect that of you your gracious as
always and and so responsive and it
couldn't be a greater treat to have you
affiliated with our fine University
um when I was mentioning to some of my
uh followers online that you were coming
I wanted to uh to highlight that this is
actually the fifth decade of this book
here the emperor's new mind uh which is
uh as I pointed out was the first
popular so to speak science book that I
ever read as a as a teenager in 1989
when it when it first came out and I've
been remarking along with my friends at
how much has changed but also how little
has changed and I thought we'd take this
opportunity on the fifth decade of this
of its existence on planet Earth to kind
of review some of the uh discoveries
that you've had and that science has
progressed since the writing of the book
I know it had a second edition and other
editions since this first edition that I
have here but I wanted to get a general
impression from you is it did this book
exceed your expectations what did it did
it sort of touch a nerve in the popular
Consciousness that it's still a
bestseller to this very day for you I'm
not sure I initially thought
that it might either disappear without
trace or that maybe there will be a
little tension to be paid to it well it
was around about the same time as
Stephen Hawking had written his book yes
the A Brief History of Time and uh I
remember asking or noting that that his
book
had been had a forward written by uh
that's right yes and uh so I thought
well I better try and do something this
and the best I could do I thought well I
thought I happened to know Martin
Gardner so right so I thought um if he
wrote a decent forward or if he's
prepared to do it first of all I wasn't
a tough show whether he'd be shocked by
the point of view I was presenting right
in fact he was very in favor of
favorable expressed he said he rather
thought of things the same way and he
wrote a very nice forward and then I
thought well perhaps it won't disappear
without Trace at least some people will
read it uh
I was very naive and I didn't expect
this sort of
mixed is the wrong word there was a lot
of antagonism from certain quarters I'm
not expected there might be people who
would object to
what I'd written from the artificial
intelligence intelligence Community
because I was trying to say it was a bit
more than
um computation going on in human
thinking and also that I might have
trouble with the religious community
because I was certainly not expressing a
religious View and I was trying to
and go against that somewhat well you're
not General religious but but somehow
that there was something outside science
which had to explain uh conscious beings
and so on what I hadn't expected was a
lot of philosophers objected to what I
was saying too I think they just thought
I was too sloppy
I was sort of expecting that there would
be a lot of young people picking up on
the ideas and maybe writing to me or
something my initial experience was
nothing of the sort they were only old
retired people who wrote to me and they
were old retired people who'd had time
to read the book I guess
and amongst the people not just the
retired and a few young people they were
usually people who got inspired by the
book
one in particular who became the
um
there was a man named Michael Michael
Wills who wrote A he was intending to
have a series of television programs on
based on the book it ended up being a
one program but he had as a researcher
somebody who was uh doing the work and
then he sort of gave up half the way
through and I thought maybe that had a
row or something and he said well
actually he'd become interested in
something else
and he actually turned out he became a
singer and he became the leading singer
in Britain tennis singer yes so I didn't
mind him he was like that one of the
people who one of the few people as a
youngster who had written to me about
the book so that's a decent excuse to
yes but one of the main things
that Agnes was a positive aspect of this
was that Stuart hammeroff read my book
right and uh he more or less wrote to me
to say well the one thing that seems to
be missing from your point of view with
these things called microtubules if you
had written the book Feeling
you know quite uh
uh I knew a bit about physics and
Mathematics and I would try and learn a
bit about neurophysiology and maybe I'll
find enough about it to see where my
ideas had any relevance to that and I
got to the end and I came to the
conclusion I didn't see any relevance
mainly that nerve propagation you said I
need to have preserve kind of some kind
of quantum coherence and I just let the
nerve propagation wasn't then there was
no hope
that the signals there's always big
electric fields which would
hear you all your Quantum clearance get
lost
in the rest of the brain and it was
completely hopeless so I sort of had a
rather feeble ending which didn't I
didn't really believe in myself but
Stuart wrote to me and said are you I
think the key thing you're missing is
these things called microtubules now I
never heard of microtubules and I had
lots of letters and email well emails
didn't exist in those things but this is
from people crackpots of one kind or
another so I thought oh here's another
you see and I thought these things look
he's got a picture of these things it
looks like it must be real so I look at
the map and I see yeah they're real all
right and it seemed to me these were
structures from Far Far More
probable plausible things which could
preserve Quantum coherence I mean it's
still a challenge a major challenge but
the account is the fact that there were
tubes and the fact they were symmetrical
in various ways and
and it looked to me there was a bit much
much better chance there so it sort of
started a collaboration with Stuart and
uh we formulated this General point of
view called orchestrated objective
reduction objective reduction is
something I'd treated in the book
but although that's one of the things I
think the exact form I had was not
correct there are a few things I would
say were wrong in the book
but not majorly wrong that is to say it
wasn't the right Criterion but it was
the sort of idea which I still believe
in namely that it's gravitation which is
the place you have to look for where
quantum mechanics
it needs something
to make it consistent the theory we have
at the moment is a combination of two
things which literally mutually
contradict each other and people sort of
live with that and try to live with it
and make sense of it but they don't
normally take the view there's something
wrong which was the view I took and
which I still hold and it's really the
second book which was Shadows of the
Mind where I more or less I introduced
the microtubules there and the point of
view which I still believe in with
regard to the
how to fix up quantum mechanics and that
the uh that the microtubules have sort
of a geometric uh connection to them or
sort of a natural geometry to them is no
surprise that appeals to your deep love
of geometry uh but is there something
deeper to it other than just their
geometric structure well I think there
is um although it's not being made use
of very much in the later developments I
mean it's already there
that is these structures that are well
actually microtubules come in two forms
they're two different lattices I didn't
know that at the time one of them are
What's called the a lattice which is
highly symmetrical and the others the B
lattice which is not quite so
symmetrical it's got a seam now on one
Edge along the tube whereas the ones
which are highly symmetrical seem to me
have a much better Prospect of
um preserving Quantum coherence so you
want Quantum effects to be preserved at
a big level and
symmetry is a good way to do that so
when you say the geometrical structure
that's part of it which is appealing to
me and there's this thing called the
yarn teller effect this is when you have
a highly symmetrical structure where
maybe uh
it could be a crystal-like thing or it
could be like a tube with different
kinds of symmetries and the high
symmetry means that you can have
well there's a sort of lowest level of
activity which is the sort of lowest
Quantum level and that is what's called
degenerate so you have information at
that level well it's called Quantum
information at that level which is
shielded from The Next Level so there's
a big gap between that level and the
next and you get that when you have very
symmetrical structures and the
microtubules yes
macrotubules and there's a lot of other
problems which it simply doesn't resolve
just like that but it gave it seemed to
me there was a lot much much more
promise in microtubules than anything
else I've seen before in in
neurophysiology so one thing that
distinguishes your research it's not
without its speculations and and new and
novel ideas but that in almost every
case that I've found in your research
you predict effects which are in
principle possible to prove wrong in
other words they are possible to be
falsified
um you know to date you've enjoyed
success and that they haven't been false
as many things have not been falsified
and in fact many of your discovery have
been have stood this test of time and
test of other experimental and
mathematical scrutiny is that something
that's important to you obviously you
you know of the and our listeners will
know of you know popper Carl popper and
his uh his sort of uh you know
objectivist and how do we how do we
determine if something is scientific
well it must be falsifiable and and I
always point out that um I believe and
you talk about girdle and his
incompleteness theorem very um
frequently in the emperor's new mind
um but I feel like physicists almost
have an Envy of girdles incompleteness
there and then in that we have no way of
of objectively showing that our
assumptions are are are built upon
perhaps in in you know incompatible uh
premises or on unprovable or
unfalsifiable uh axioms and I wonder you
know to what extent do you are you
Guided by copper and the falsification
demarcation theory is that something
that's important to you would you you
work on something that is not because it
could be tomorrow our colleagues find
that microtubules are just impossible to
be you know they they can't maintain
coherence Beyond you know nanosecond
level time scale something like that
well you see I think your point is is
well taken but there is a major part of
what I've done in relation to physics
and how it relates to mathematics which
at least as yet has not been falsifiable
yeah and you know I rather regret the
fact that it's not this is the theory
which I refer to as twister Theory now
it's very much
motivated by relativity facts and uh
curious things like the the nature of
the celestial sphere you think of the
sky that's a sphere and the structure of
that sky is what's called a conformal
structure and this is a thing I got
interested in very early that if you
imagine two space Travelers
getting passing each other very close
and they look at the same sky but
they're traveling at almost
very close to the speed of light one
with respect to the other and they look
up at this game sky and there's a
distortion of the sky they see the stars
are slightly different spots and so on
there's something collaboration which
has to do with emotion but it has a very
curious feature that it preserves angles
not to say if you if you imagined an
angle in the sky it's two three stars
close together and at a certain angle
that the other Observer would see the
same angle so it's what the
transformation of one Observer to the
sky to the other is what's called
conformal and this is a kind of geometry
which I got very interested in uh called
conformal geometry I mean we know about
euclidean geometry that's to do with
links but this is to do with angles and
it's a much richer geometry and the fact
that it applies to the sky
is an indication of something in
completely different subject the
you might say the two big Revolutions of
20th century physics one is relativity
and here we see in special relativity it
doesn't work in Newtonian Theory right
relativity the Ang the conformal nature
of the transformation of the sky but the
other is in quantum mechanics and you
have these complex numbers which are all
intimately related to this conformal
structure
and they play a big role when you think
about spins of particles and again you
get this same sphere which is a
conformal sphere playing a fundamental
role in physics and this has to do with
the complex numbers which involve the
square root of minus one sort of
mysterious numbers which are at the
basis of quantum mechanics
and so I kind of thought of this as a
link between
relativity and quantum mechanics and
twister Theory I won't go into it here
but it's it's a mathematical formalism
it has particular features one of them
it's you have to have three space
dimensions in one time Dimension so when
I was being confronted with things like
string theory I quite like the idea when
strings were initially put forward but
when they seem to consider you needed to
have 26 dimensions of space-time or 10
Dimensions or both together in some
Curious way it didn't appeal to me at
all because the link between the quantum
mechanics and and relativity which is
through this conformal sphere only works
when you have three space dimensions in
one time Dimension and so the theory
which I developed which I call twister
Theory
was based upon this very specific
structure and it doesn't work in other
numbers well you can start doing it in
another dimension it doesn't really work
and it took me years and years to try
and make it work with general relativity
and only relatively recently did I see
how these things fit together and with
quantum mechanics and
curious feature is that it needs to have
this was a big blow to me initially the
cosmological constant see this was this
number introduced by Einstein
in 1917 for the wrong reason you see he
wanted a static Universe he liked a
universe which was sort of spherical in
space so it closed up on itself and sort
of sat there forever
and this was just about at the time when
people were becoming convinced that the
Universe was expanding
but Einstein introduced this
cosmological constant term could be
usually called it Lambda like a V upside
down and this was
as soon as he was convinced that the
Universe was actually expanding and this
model doesn't work he sort of retracted
this cosmological term and regarded it
as his greatest blunder
now you see all the cosmology books were
sort of oh Einstein says this number has
to be there and so they all considered a
cosmological constant and so on so
and I sort of like everybody else a lot
of people thought well it shouldn't
really be there it's much nicer not
having it there and my trying to solve a
big problem in twister Theory I thought
I needed it to be zero and I remember
having this conversation with uh with
Jerry our Striker and I was saying do we
really have to believe from these stupid
distant super no they were observations
of distant exploding stars supernovae
that there seemed to be evidence for
this expansion exponential expansion of
the universe over and Beyond
the expansion that we already thought
was consistent with the Einstein
equations and that seemed to indicate
that there was this cosmological
constant the line standard regarded as
biggest blunder it had to be there it
had to be positive and I said to Jerry I
said well do we really have to believe
that I mean because perhaps it's just
dust out there as many people said and
he looked at me and said look that's not
the point there are so many things in
cosmology that are much better
understood they work so much better with
this cosmological term
and I thought okay I'll give you I'm
prepared to give it up before you say so
it was a good thing because the later
views that I had absolutely depend on
having this cosmological constant it has
to be positive it has to be there we
have to see this exponential expansion
and if it hadn't been for Jerry
convincing me it was there I'd have been
still going down the wrong route that I
was going down before uh no we say you
know Einstein's biggest blunder turned
out to be that he called it a blunder
actually I guess he wasn't right in the
way he was using it that's right but it
was uh I mean it was a great Insight
because that's basically the only thing
you could do to his equations without
wrecking them yeah and he knew you could
do that and he had great confidence in
the equations absolutely especially as
uh after the 1919 the Addington Eclipse
so in the book one thing that helped me
as a young you know uh scientifically
mathematically inclined uh young person
when I read this in 1989 was
um the way that you very carefully lay
out your your opinions but in a very
even-handed fashion as to different
theories of math and physics and and and
you kind of give a rank ordering to them
which you which you talk about and I
want to revisit that on this you know
yeah so the categories I have them here
are tentative useful and superb and one
of the most amazing things you do is you
start off with Euclid and you say Euclid
euclidean geometry is actually in it was
in your characterization a physical
Theory and I wonder if you can talk more
about that yeah
I mean I guess uh
it's an interesting question how the
Ancients looked at it
um I mean the the ideas of
euclidean geometry we're sort of based
on angles and lengths and triangles and
sort of the view that a big triangle and
a little triangle the same geometry
applied if you had a really huge
triangle and if you added up its angles
it would still add up to 180 degrees
and uh and people tried there was a big
activity where
um I forgetting his name now this chap
who tried to prove
that the angles had to add up I mean
Euclid realized that there was a puzzle
here that you needed to have a special
assumption which it was the parallel
postulate usually phrased in terms of if
you have a land in the plane and a point
in that plane which is not on the line
then there is only exactly one line
straight line through that point which
didn't meet the other line and and it
was thought that somehow you should be
able to deduce that from the others and
it was a real insight yeah for Euclid to
see that that was an independent
assumption right and uh and it took not
just the Ancients but many people and
they tried to prove it and sakiri and
spent his entire life trying to prove it
and at the end
more or less discovered what's called
hyperbolic geometry and there are other
people who uh what was his name
Lambert was somebody who proved
beautiful theorems which had to depend
on this other kind of geometry that
people didn't think existed and about
how you add up the angles of a triangle
and how much they fall short of 180
degrees as a measure of the angle of the
triangle area of the triangle an amazing
thing and how could you prove a thing
like when when you don't believe that
that there is any other geometry I don't
know it very interesting to know what
what Lambert's psyche was here I think
he probably at certain times of his life
thought there was a that it was
consistent to have different times of
geometry and other types he probably
thought he was absurd because you had to
catch the types times when you thought
it was consistent because he had this
beautiful theorem in it
but then and Gauss who more importantly
trying to find well it's an interesting
question because he he part of his
job was to do geodesic so he's actually
measuring very big triangles the
mountaintops and people are trying to
think oh well he's just doing you ought
to say and he's but I think at the back
of his mind he was really trying to see
whether the geometry was the euclidean
or not because he knew he knew that
there were other kinds of geometry right
and it was really interesting how the
history people kind of toying with were
there other kinds of General but the
fact that euclidean geometry is so
precise
and it was sort of laid out as this
wonderful Theory which it is an amazing
Theory and it lasted a few minutes knows
how many centuries yeah before people a
discovered there were other kinds of
geometries and B with Einstein and uh
um well primarily Einstein but realizing
that you needed to her in order to
describe
a physics in which
the principle of equivalence that is
again a thing
a lot of these ideas are ancient but
people didn't know quite what
significance was I mean this was going
back to Galileo it's not just going back
to
Archimedes and and going back to uh
Euclid people but the fact that a
gravitational field
is equivalent to an acceleration and so
Galloway was extremely insightful and
you imagine you know dropping these
things from the in a bone Tower or
whatever it was and they fall together
and they somehow you can cancel out
gravity and there's a wonderful
description he has in
in one of his books where he talks about
fireworks and you see the fireworks and
they explode and you see these spheres
beautiful spheres and they come they
come and they fall and they remain
spheres right and he pointed this out
and there was a deep Insight in that
it's just as though there was no gravity
and the acceleration you
if you're free freely falling it's as
though there's no experience now that's
a huge Insight which had to wait until
Einstein to realize the importance of it
yeah that's right yeah that was in the
discourse I think the last book that
Galileo wrote yes so I want to read from
emperor's new mind a paragraph that
speaks to me to this very dang and I
remember being moved by it way back when
he said great works of art are indeed
closer to God than our lesser ones it is
a feeling not uncommon amongst artists
that in their greatest works they are
revealing Eternal truths which have some
kind of Prior ethereal existence while
there are lesser Works may be more
arbitrary of nature more Mortal
constructions likewise in engineering
Innovation with a beautiful economy
uh where a great deal is achieved in the
scope of the application of some simple
unexpected idea might appropriately be
described as a discovery rather than an
invention now this Harkens back to
whether or not mathematical truths are
in some way discovered or invented and I
wonder if you can weigh in with your
vast experience glean both before and
after this book and where do you feel
fall now
well I certainly haven't changed my view
in that particular respect I haven't
certain others
yeah I think the mathematics
well it's a platonic view you would say
that the mathematics
has its own world you see I like to do
this with an illustration which I think
first had in in Shadows of the Mind
where I had three types of existence in
a sense and if you're a mathematician
you very strongly get the feeling that
it's like a bit like geology or
archeology or something you're exploring
a world oh yeah you're discovering
things which are out there you don't
invent the theorems you discover truths
which are in some sense out there in a
world but it's not the world the
physical world because the things you
find that you know you try to draw a
triangle and it's not quite and how do
you draw a straight line when the more
you know about the nature of matter you
see it's granular in certain respects
yeah you talk in here about what is the
number three
yes very difficult and so you when you
think about the mathematics you really
have to think about it in this platonic
way uh it's not that you're creating it
I mean you sometimes do things which are
simply especially while that they look
as though you've um you've made made it
all up but in a certain sense if it
really works beautifully there's
something out there which is
out of your control and it's much more
like exploration
you could say this is a feeling that one
has but it's more
I think strong you see this is one of
the worlds the world the platonic World
which of mathematics which I sort of
draw is this sphere at the top of the
picture and then a little bit of that
world and it's only a very tiny bit
because if you you look at any article
and or any Journal of pure mathematics
and you will see the articles in there
which have any relevance whatsoever to
the physical world right very very tiny
yeah and the money that I have another
number in it
that's right and it's a very tiny bit of
it which sometimes it turns out later
things that you find well in behind this
this beautiful theorem which was in that
pure mathematical work and and now it's
found an application so you see that but
when you think of the whole totality of
a mathematical work that's been done
that's explored if you like it's a
really tiny part of that world a very
um productive magical particularly
magical part of that world which seems
to be and I have it sort of projecting
out to the physical world the laws that
we see being extraordinarily precise
well I say uh euclidean geometries even
though not we know no not exactly
mirrored in the in the geometry of the
physical world
it's a basic ingredient of everything we
think about in geometry
so it has a huge impact into into into
physics
but then the more we learn about physics
it's governed by equations and
geometrical ideas and things
and we reduce them to mathematics and in
that mathematics we can gain enormous
Precision in the way we describe and
understand the way the physical world
operates now this is a
in some sense The View we have and this
is the view I have is that this small
part of the mathematical World
encompasses in a certain sense the whole
of a physical world so I draw this in
this rather strange way a little tiny
part of the world the mathematical world
seems to Encompass the behavior of this
physical world we've seen it seems to be
when we get our laws right
they really be it almost is that we
reduce them to mathematics you might say
well what is a what is a rock well this
rock is made of
molecules and things like that and what
are the molecules made of holy made of
atoms what are the atoms made of what
they're made of fundamental particles
electrons and
and you worry about the neutrons and
protons and then the gluons and things
but sticks the particles together are
they particles themselves well then you
worry about the photons well you have to
use this there used to be fields and
then you see their particles but then
you say what is an electron well the
best you can do is it's a solution of
the Dirac equation you say well that's a
pretty abstract note and you kind of
have to resort to mathematics when you
try to probe reality at its deepest
levels and then there's the next
question you see which is my third world
which is the world of conscious
experience and so the type of view I'm
expressing well both in the emperor's
demand and shadows of them are more more
explicitly in in this picture is that
there's a third world which is the world
of conscious experience
some people take that as primary and
they try to build everything else out of
that I think that's pretty hopeless task
because
they are sensory experiences are very
hard to describe any of these other
things in a in a precise way but
nevertheless that's one we'll have
different ways of looking at it but
again it seems to be a very small part
of the world of physics
which is actually supports consciousness
so okay human beings sure
I think it extends much more broadly
than that and animals maybe many animals
but not all animals I wouldn't know but
certainly I think the difference between
human beings and
and certain animals is
okay great in certain respects but not
fundamental I think the people who are
dog owners for example are pretty
convinced their dogs are conscious I
think octopus is a conscious elephants
are way down though below that I think
my subconscious too aren't they nice I
used to have infestations of mice in the
place I used to live in and like you can
either Mar the cleverness of these
little creatures sometimes ah they could
step over the Trap that way quite
deliberately and take out all all the
food completely clean that and they
hadn't touched the thing which would
trip them up I just had a great
admiration for the mice so there's
something which goes deep down into the
into the world but it's still a tiny
part in this physical world you know in
the Penrose hierarchy of of
um you know superb useful and tentative
yes where do you rank because obviously
geometry is superb and obviously
mathematics is superb well mathematics
is I would say you have to spread it out
it's not just mathematics is itself in
itself but do you feel in principle a
theory of consciousness
could be superb is it possible for it to
be superb or is it only possible for it
to be useful
I think if we get it right we're a long
way what would it look like what would
such a theory
all I can say about it in the studies of
the books I've written is a little chip
I would say and the tiny thing I'm
trying to say
is that
Consciousness well again it's a little
part Consciousness in first all sorts of
things you know pain and perception of
the color blue and happiness and love
and and all sorts of things
um I don't talk about most of those
things in my book I just talk about the
one thing that I could say anything
about which is understanding
and I concentrate on that because
there are these theorems of logic most
particularly
girdles theorem and turing's Analysis of
of it in terms of computation the ideas
of computation and so on
lead me to believe that human
understanding
is not computable it's not a computation
and the and a lot of people that's the
way a lot of people argued with me
because somehow it tells us that an
algorithm you see we we have these
wonderful computers and what they can do
they do incredible things I agree with
that but they run on algorithms and this
is what we understand this notion of an
algorithm which was well it really goes
back to what it was Arabic now here is
me but that was during and a few other
people posts and church and people who
really made clear the idea of what an
algorithm is what a computation is and
the girdle theorem tells you that our
understanding is not a computation I
mean this is a story which is you know a
lot of people complain about but I think
the argument is pretty clear that what
we do when we understand a proof in
mathematics
is not following an algorithms and it's
very clear because of the girdle thing
right it says whenever you what do you
mean by proof you see well proof is
using certain kinds of rules and you
have to use them correctly and if you
really think of it as a proof you've got
to believe that those rules only give
you true statements now it's that thing
the belief that it only gives you true
statements which enables you to
demonstrate the truth of a proposition
which girdle produces very ingeniously a
proposition which you can see must be
true
nevertheless it cannot be derived by
means of whatever rules you start with
as long as you believe those rules only
give you truth then you must believe
this girdle statement is also true and
not derivable by means of those rules
now when I learned that I was stunned by
it you see it wasn't that you can prove
certain things can't derived in certain
ways it's much stronger than that say
whatever procedure you use if it's
following defense definite rules
algorithms which you believe in trust
the algorithm that you trust then you
can see how to transcend that now what
is it in in our abilities to think
perceive
conscious perception
that transcends computation oh there are
lots of arguments people present and one
of these is well you know the algorithm
we use in our heads are so complicated
that we'll never be able to see what the
girdle thing is we are sure but the
point is that
how did it come about by natural
selection it has to have been by
relatively simple things which we can
certainly understand these very
complicated things which
you can maybe have a computer which
could do things which are pretty hard to
see why they're true because it's very
very elaborate that's not what was
naturally selected for what was
naturally selected for was this more
basic principle of an understanding and
that is not a computation it's something
I don't know what it is don't ask me
what it is that's the distinguishing
between computability and actual
comprehension and it's the comprehension
of why the algorithm does what it's
supposed to do and it's not simply
trying this and that and that zillion
still inductively in a certain sense I
mean there's an irony here because okay
uh conscious beings came about
in a way by Natural Selections and which
is an algorithmic right some way of
picking out the ones that were more
successful but they were successful in
the view I hold by
probing the laws of physics at a much
deeper level than we've seen yet at this
level where we see non-computable action
and this has to be
still yeah it was already the argument I
gave in the in the emperor's new mind
but although not quite the right
criteria in my view it has to be at this
place where we have to go beyond current
Quantum Theory
and the argument came about
right which is what formula is the view
basically when I was my
I think it was my first year as a
graduate student when I went to courses
by
a man called Steen of mathematical logic
Bondi on general relativity and Dirac a
great Quantum physicist on quantum
mechanics and I tried to see what in the
physical world can be not put on a
computer basically and basically my
conclusion was it was this curious
feature of quantum mechanics
where you have an inconsistency it's
basically making a measurement you see
quantum theory consists of two parts one
is following an equation
and it just that's a thing you could put
on a computer unitary Evolution unitary
Evolution and the other is where you
don't do uniform Solutions right you
make a measurement plan to collapse the
wave function and you cheat but you have
to do that right to to have the world we
see and so this scene to me that's the
place where the non-computable physics
has to come in I don't see in detail how
it comes in and it's a big mystery but
my claim is you've got to harness that
bit
and somehow the conscious brain
is at some point making use of this part
of
this place is not just that it uses
quantum mechanics many people that
already they say oh no it's classical
physics or you don't know what a
economic is no when we see that's wrong
already because in things like uh
photosynthesis and maybe bird migration
there are other places where we seem to
see
effects which do just depend on
crucially on Quantum effects well
chemistry is already Quantum these are
things a little bit outside that saying
like room temperature yes
preserving of quantum coherence at room
temperature so sure the argument is
nature has found a way to do it deep in
the in the brain and much more likely
it'll be to do with microtubules
um and probably
how they relate to other structures
and um so anything with a microtubule
could participate in quantum mechanical
measurements even it doesn't say that
much I mean there are these two
structures the a lattice and the B
Latins and the a lattice is very
symmetrical the B lens is not so
symmetrical the realized it's still
symmetrical but not so much and most
microtubules in the body all over the
place tend to be B lattice
the eyelashes ones seem to be much more
promising for
doing things in the brain probably and
maybe conscious actions so the guess is
that whatever is really responsible for
conscious action is not just
microtubules that a lettuce macrotubules
and there is some theoretical work done
by various people which does seem to
indicate that that's certainly for the
future and I think that's way ahead of
what we have at the moment are there
models you know mice or octopi or yeah I
mean are we able to test in living
structures that these things can occur I
mean uh Schrodinger cat experiment
supervised by an octopus or something
that the folks at Peter wanted I think
going to that level
is unlikely for a while for a long term
I think it's much more likely probing uh
areas of the brain not so much areas of
the brain but exactly what's going on
when
and there are things uh you know it's
outside my area of expertise but they're
sort of
waves of activity involving different
layers in the brain and where the
conscious activity seems to come in is
where there are large numbers of these
certain kinds of cells called pyramidal
cells
I'm I don't know enough about it to know
exactly
there is a big question you see which
people often raise and that is
there are far more cells neurons I only
reasonably then it's more I knew it was
comparable yeah in this part of the
brain called the cerebellum now the
cerebellum it's not that people usually
but people who think of it's just as
hard at the top with adults convolutions
all that it's a part which looks much
more like a ball of knitting underneath
and at the back it has more neurons
considerably more than they are and more
connections between neurons and it seems
to be pretty well unconscious it's it's
activated when you do very precise
motions you know if you become an expert
tennis player or play the piano
beautifully well you don't think every
moment you know where do I put my middle
fingers in exactly what spot
that's controlled pretty well by
unconscious actions and the Precision
needed in these actions are carried up
by the cerebellum I mean they initially
you have to learn about them in the
cerebrum part but when they become
unconscious controlled with such
unconscious Precision that you need at
these great levels of expertise or even
when you're walking down the street
probably certainly when you're driving
the car not thinking about it is
probably controlled by the cerebellum
now that doesn't seem to be conscious
right what's the difference well I don't
know but Stuart would say there's no
there are no pyramidal cells in the
cerebellum and the pyramidal cells have
many more microtubles in them and
they're organized in a different way
from those
that's the kind of thing one could
Explore More and see to what extent
is it that these structures with more
microtubules and more analytus
microtubules maybe actually seem to be
more concerned with conscious thinking
and you can definitely true that some
parts of the brain are much much more to
do with Consciousness than others right
that's certainly true of the with the
the cerebellum I don't know what the
question is with other parts of the
cerebrum you know on a practical level
I'm curious to get your perspective on
recent developments and things like
Quantum Computing you you very
presciently talked in this book about
not only chess and this is before deep
blue it defeated Gary Kasper off but you
talked about the game go which is uh
which was recently Google's version of
the goal playing algorithm beat it uh
the best human human being uh you talked
about all these things in the late 80s
it's really it's really amusing to look
back uh the other things you talked
about quantum teleportation there's a
Charming uh chapter where you talk about
you know taking the molecules of a brick
and and replacing them and is it the
same brick and then what's the
difference in the brink in your brain
and could you do these things you know
to this so I'm interested with all the
technological developments in Quantum
Computing that we've recently achieved
Quantum Supremacy and things like that
what's your uh from the standpoint of
the Long View of History how important
is this era in modern in modern times
how will you feel like it will be
regarded in the future was this a
critical time or is it it's very hard
for me to judge at the moment I mean
certainly the quantum computers that
they have now and they've made a lot of
progress are not like the ones that were
being considered before where you might
have something like a classical computer
but then you're sort of introduced
Quantum superpositions and calculations
and so on they're basically different
kinds of structure and they're not as
far as I know really Universal machines
see one of the wonderful things about
ordinary computers if I can call them
ordinary is that depending on this
notion developed by touring and church
and posts and girdle and people of
computability being a universal concept
so you can build up through very simple
ingredients a machine which can in
principle do any computation now this is
these ideas are developed into of course
lots of ingenious ideas go into it but
the modern computers are basically
Universal Computing machines so any kind
of algorithm
you can put on the computer now with the
quantum machines it's really a very
small number of problems okay there's
very specific ones they can do very well
simulated hamiltonians right yeah as far
as I'm aware they're not really general
purpose machines so it's it's not really
quite level maybe they will become and
maybe there will be a point which you
sound like sometimes commenting on this
see in the old days people used to say
well you get better computers this is
before the quantum computer screen you
get better better machines the smaller
you make them so you can get smaller and
smaller chips and then they become
smaller and smaller and smaller and they
much more effective and you get more
power out of the machine and then
there's a certain limit because at a
certain point you run into the problems
of quantum mechanics so there is say the
quantum limits you see that'll stick us
up at some point well then of course
people say no well once you know what's
going on at the quantum level you can
actually harness the quantum level so
you have this idea of a quite computer
which enables you to transcend this to
some degree what you can do with a
classical machine and so maybe something
similar might come later on now people
say well there's a certain level a limit
to what you can do with your Quantum
machines because it's if you have too
much mass moving around then you're
going to run into the limit where the
quantum mechanics doesn't hold and
you've got to go beyond it and so there
will be a limit there the state
reduction limit of quantum computers and
then maybe someone said well we've got
maybe by then some great Theory which
tells you which goes beyond standard
quantum mechanics and then maybe you can
do construct a device which goes beyond
it by taking advantage of this thing I
think I'm gonna I'm glad I won't be
alive by then
I I think if these things do come about
I'm a little bit worried about what
we're going to be done with them yeah I
wish you a long life I wish that that
that's the only thing I disagree with
you I don't I don't want you to not to
to leave the Mortal coil too soon
because I I want to see actually that
segues maybe it's perhaps to my final
question which
um has to do with all these various
um novel ideas that you've had and
perhaps no other certainly no other
modern physicist has had contributions
as diverse as cosmology as Consciousness
as a twister Theory as uh the talking
computation and artificial intelligence
if you could ask you know as Einstein
used to call him the old one God if you
could if you get the answer to one of
these you know many topics that you've
that you've researched you know
throughout your life throughout your
very productive career which is the
thing that most fascinates you which is
the thing that most captivates your your
imagination question because at the
moment the thing which excites me most
is the cosmology but there he says
explains to me because you see I have a
certain wild idea which I think May well
be true and most standard cosmologists
don't believe me you see but there are
bits of evidence what we're beginning to
see which do suggest that maybe there is
some truth in this model
and then just thinking about that just
for the listeners you're speaking about
the conformal psychics which says that
the Big Bang was not really the
beginning it was the conformal
continuation I talked about the
conformal geometry where big and small
you're not interested in you're
uninterested in size but what I'm trying
to say is in the Big Bang
because the energies are so big and the
particles become effectively massless
they can't tell big from small so at
that stage there's the kind of geometry
doesn't know big from small is important
the other place when you can't tell big
from small is an extremely a remote
future where the universe expands and
expands exponentially and you mostly
photons running around and they don't
know big from small and you've got the
black holes and then they eventually
evaporate Away by Hawking evaporation
and then you've got nothing left that
doesn't it's not quite true you have to
be careful about that but roughly
speaking the idea is that this very
remote future it doesn't go big from
small either so the crazy idea is that
this very remote future
joins on to the Big Bang of a next Eon
and our big bang was the conformally
squashed remote future of a previous Eon
now it's a completely wild idea because
my intensity well why you know how does
this happen no right stretched out very
rarified very cold infinite remote
future of a neon simply become the very
concentrated extremely hot and dense
next big bang well the thing is because
the geometry there is the conformal one
the big and smaller equivalent okay you
take people a lot of convincing to make
sure that they believe this but the
claim is that we're making is that there
are certain signals which you can which
do get through and the first ones we're
thinking were super massive black holes
railing into each other and producing
and huge bursts of gravitational
radiation which would give you signals
which could get through and we claim
that there are such indications
much stronger are the more recent
observations this is different so one
mustn't get them confused the link
between the two is supermassive black
holes but now this is the black holes in
the very remote future the basically
swallowed up in an entire cluster of
galaxies
and the entire pretty well most of the
mass in that cluster of Galaxy if we get
swallowed by the black hole sits around
it sits around and sits around and
eventually
gets evaporates Away by Hawking
evaporation into into photons
you see I used to think it's very boring
phase of the universe when you've got
nothing but black holes left what's
really boring is when they've all
evaporated away and so I was worrying
about this in unbelievably boring
universe and then I began to think well
who's going to be bored by it yeah
exactly you're right that's the only the
30 is a pretty long time that's right
it's an awful long time especially at
the end
but uh the main point here is that
photons don't experience
eternity because they've got the clocks
yeah there's no clocks yeah they don't
have clocks so
so the infinity is no big big deal to a
photon it just Zips through into the
next neon and that's the view I had then
tried to make it into a theory and these
Hawking points which are the
splodges I would say it may Hawking
splodge but it's pretty circular it
would be they would be spots in the sky
about 10 times sorry eight times the
diameter of the full moon and you
wouldn't see them any bigger than that
that's definitely a prediction of the
theory
occasionally a bit smaller but they
would be slightly raised temperature
and I don't know this is my suggestion
that if you had a planetarium
you know usually the UC stars and
planets and things like that have the
microwave background on your planetarium
with enough detail yes I guess the flank
satellite would reveal and you look at
appetite and you would see them I'd like
to know if that's true we have a beach
ball behind you which will work yeah
that's right you need a bit more
resolution because I think there's a
little spot it turns the moon damage it
would look like a pin prick in that
model so it needs to be a bit bigger
than that but the intensity
overall is about 15 times the average
increased temperatures that you see so
the the new the normal variations in
temperature
or what 10 to the minus five and here
you're looking at about ten for minus
four a little bit a little bit more of
an intensity
but probably not too obvious unless
I don't know I would expect you know you
look at that in the sky and you'd see
them I'd like to know I'd like to have a
good well-known Planetarium and I'd like
to sit in it and see yeah you can see
well you and I both have the pleasure at
one point or another of speaking at the
Hayden Planetarium and when I spoke
there they were kind enough to project
onto the Dome the CMB map is revealed
from from the Planck satellites they did
do it so maybe we can arrange it for
your next visit to New York City yeah if
it's really just a startling it's almost
induced vertigo in me which was to be
centered on this universe that I'd spent
so much time studying I would love to
see it yeah it's quite beautiful and he
said nowhere to look for some of them
the five most prominent spots right I
suppose but but it's intriguing to know
whether whether you would really see
them
naked eye with liquid yeah radiation so
you were asking me what yeah I mean
that's what excites me most at the
moment because that's ongoing and you
can really see does this conform to
right does the theory conform to the
observations are not out the next thing
I would say would be the state reduction
experiments which are a little way off
but not that long there are experiments
currently being done
which within the next three years
maybe we'll get an answer there are
other experiments the one I'm thinking
of are the ones that by Dirk by me sir
and this is his estimate and he's been
pretty accurate in in predicting how
long his things will be so I think he
may have an answer because the answer
May then go the wrong way as far as I'm
concerned but I hope he will see State
reduction that's a sort of deviation
from standard quantum mechanics right of
course since it's a dedicated deviation
a lot of people will complain they'll
say that's a bad experiment it's due to
decoherence and all that so I have to
you'll have to persuade them this is a
good experiment but there are other
experiments using boson sign condensates
I think they're probably the next
maybe they they will see effects
um right I have a colleague in
Nottingham Yvette Fuentes right
has proposals which I hope will be
performed experimental they haven't been
set up yet and the third thing is
consciousness the head there you see I
think we're a lot longer I think the
we may see the effect in the not
biological experiments but the just the
the physical physics experiments are
being done there whether you will see
the quantum effects in microtubules or
what quite possibly
I think some general evidence for
Quantum coherence
in biological systems might not be too
long from now but to see any direct
evidence of connections with
Consciousness I think it's a long way
off because that's really such a
slippery subject right to to get hold of
that in an experimental way may be
really tricky but that moment maybe well
if emperor's new mind which is still
relevant now in its fifth decade after
publication there's any guide uh it's
surely to be expected that we'll have
various new insights into these
fascinating subjects that you've worked
on and I can't tell you how much we
appreciate you here your graciousness is
always in visiting us and sharing your
ideas and opinions with us are really
very much appreciated so thank you sir
Roger for your visit and we look forward
to many years of continuing to success
well thank you very much and I'm very
excited to see how many now these
experiments in the telescope and Chile
and all that will come along it really
sounds like a very exciting project
thank you very much
the only thing they can be sure of about
the future is that it will be absolutely
fantastic
[Music]